mikel es bombardeada por quinta vez esta
semana a la capital de la región hecho
pérez y ha recibido la ofensiva militar
el gobierno dice que está atacando
instalaciones militares del type lf el
movimiento rebelde con el que el régimen
de addis abeba está en guerra desde
noviembre de 2020 el viernes un ataque
aéreo obligó a un avión humanitario de
la onu a dar la vuelta y llevó a la
organización a suspender sus dos vuelos
semanales a la región amenazada por la
hambruna
puedo confirmar que el gobierno fue
informado de este vuelo antes de que
despegara y también puedo confirmar que
el vuelo se vio obligado a dar marcha
atrás a mitad de vuelo debido a los
acontecimientos en tierra obviamente nos
preocupa lo que ha ocurrido hoy y lo que
significa para las operaciones
humanitarias en el norte de etiopía en
el futuro
los ataques suponen una nueva escalada
en el conflicto de casi un año de
duración a finales de 2020 el primer
ministro había ahmed envió al ejército
al norte del país para expulsar a las
autoridades regionales disidentes del
antiguo partido gobernante tlf pero tras
meses de conflicto mortal y el anuncio
de un alto al fuego por parte de allí
sabed a los rebeldes de recuperaron la
mayor parte del territorio y extendieron
sus conquistas a las regiones vecinas
hace dos semanas el gobierno lanzó una
contraofensiva masiva en el espacio de
un año el conflicto ha matado a miles de
personas y ha desplazado a más de dos
millones